que nous reprenions nos nos travaux
alors cette matinée est un peu difficile
parce que aucun être humain même
sénateur n'est n'est doté du don
d'ubiquité et il y a plusieurs choses en
même temps y compris des mises en place
encore de délégation donc un certain
nombre de nos collègues sont sont
excusés mais je voulais vraiment vous
remercier Madame la
vice-présidente chère Catherine d'avoir
pris le temps euh de de de venir nous
nous rencontrer euh parce que je sais le
travail important que vous avez accompli
le président David lisna merci beaucoup
le président David lisna en en a
beaucoup parler il en était beaucoup
question c'était avanttiier n'est-ce pas
à la convention organisée en partenariat
avec la MF par la la ministre de de la
cohésion des territoirees euh nous
sommes sur sur un sujet majeur
euh on sait aujourd'hui la fragilité de
de l'engagement des élus le nombre des
démissions qui n'a cessé d'augmenter
pour des motifs divers et varié on pense
très souvent aux agressions dont sont
victimes les élus mais il y a aussi
cette énorme lassitude et cet épuisement
qui n'est de ce sentiment de de
découragement parce que les élus se
rendre compte qu'il devient très
difficile d'agir de remplir les missions
qui sont les leurs au service des des
habitants et qu'on a un enjeu
aujourd'hui de
démocratie vraiment qui est fort
préoccupant parce que alors la MF
naturellement c'est son ADN mais c'est
aussi l'ADN du du Sénat nous nous sommes
persuadés et convaincus que la commune
est le premier échelon le premier
maillon le premier kilomètre de la
démocratie
et que
si l'engagement citoyen est
fragilisé on n'ose pas imaginer ce que
serait on va dire l'état de de de de ce
pays je rappelais hier parce que nous
auditionnons des universitaires sur ce
que nous appelons d'une manière injuste
mais bon on n pas trouvé d'autres mot le
statut de
l'élu que en c'était en 2014 je crois il
y avait à peu près 80 communes candidat
106 en 2020 et que ce dont on parle
moins mais qui est tout aussi important
c'est le fait que dans des communes de
taille y compris 10000 habitants il n'y
a qu'une seule liste ce qui n'est pas
sans poser problème quand on a des
démissions et cetera donc le Sénat vous
le savez porte encore une fois au cœur
de de de son action ce souci des des
collectivités et ce pouvoir voir d'agir
qui était le titre très juste de votre
congrès l'année dernière et le fait que
l'État peut décider de politique
stratégique et c'est son rôle dans sa
fonction égalienne mais que rien ne se
fera et on restera au niveau des
discours et des intentions si l'armée
des élus locaux n'exerce pas la mise en
œuvre jusqu'au dernier kilomètre donc un
certain nombre de travaux ont été menés
au Sénat depuis longtemps il y a eu un
rapport extrêmement important an en 2018
d'ailleurs conduit par la délégation
c'est à l'époque Jean-Marie Boquel qui
qui
présidait le Sénat a aussi conduit des
des missions
transpartisanes en 2020 en remettant au
président de la République des
propositions pour retrouver on va dire
une efficience de l'action publique
jusqu'au dernier kilomètre et nous avons
à nouveau sous la présidence de Gérard
Larcher conduit une mission
transpartisane qui nous a euh enfin qui
a conduit à la présentation de
propositions pour améliorer les choses
alors moi je pense que les diagnostics
alors on sait tous Voilà il y a plein de
docteurs et de médecins qui sont penchés
sur le truc donc voilà diagnostic on
sait donc maintenant c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait euh et quand on le fait parce
que il y a une vraie urgence et c'est
pour ça que le Sénat au travers de la
délégation mais c'est un souhait du du
président
Larcher a décidé de de lancer cette
mission que nous appelons flash alors
pourquoi flash c'est pas parce que nous
allons la faire comme ça très rapidement
mais c'est parce que nous avons toute la
matière et que je tiens à saluer les
contributions des associations d'élus
extrêmement dense extrêmement complète
don celle de de la MF donc maintenant il
s'agit de faire des propositions et donc
la délégation qui s'est reconstitué il y
a très peu de temps voilà a lancé cette
mission fl sur le statut de l'élu c'est
plutôt ce qu'on pourra appeler droit et
obligation des
élus qui
aboutira en décembre enfin mi midécembre
et qui comporte trois volets le premier
volet qui sera présenté la semaine
prochaine porte sur les indemnités des
élus le deuxième volet porte sur la
facilitation de l'engagement et
l'exercice du mandat c'est veut dire que
dedans il y a des questions de
simplification des questions de
formation d'autorisation d'absence voilà
et le troisème volet qui est tout aussi
important parce que quand on s'engage il
faut aussi être sécurisé sur la sortie
du mandat parce qu'on connaît beaucoup
d'élus locaux et je parle des maires des
adjoints et des conseillers municipaux
qui s'engagent et qui un dimanchoir
c'est souvent en
mars soit parce qu'ils ont décidé de ne
pas se représenter doivent préparer leur
après eu soit à l'insu de leur plein gré
le dimanche soir vers 20h ils apprennent
que le lundi matin leur vie va va
changer et que je pense que on ne
permettra le maintien de cet engagement
citoyen que si on sécurise aussi
l'prês voilà madame la vice-présidente
chère Catherine l'objet de de nos
travaux nous sommes neu sénateurs à
travailler 11 même pardon à travailler
sur ces sur ces rapports d'à peu près
tous les groupes et je crois qu'on a il
y a un
consensus très fort sur la nécessité
alors sans doute avec des des des des
variations sur les sujets voilà et il
nous semblait extrêmement euh important
euh de de vous entendre aujourd'hui
au-delà de la qualité de votre
contribution que l'on allume et ça
permet un échange qui associe les
collègues donc je ne serai pas plus
longue madame la vice-présidente voilà
je vous laisse la parole chère
Catherine merci madame la Présidente et
je voulais vous remercier de l'attention
que cette délégation porte à cette
question remercier remercier aussi les
membres de la délégation qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet euh vous avez
effectivement parfaitement décrit ce que
nous ressentons tous hein c'est-à-dire
cette ce risque pour la démocratie si
nous n'arrivons pas à conforter
l'engagement de nos concitoyens pour
gérer la C je pense que c'est
fondamental on le voit bien c'est la
démocratie de proximité c'est l'endroit
où nos concitoyens vont directement
lorsqu'ils ont des soucis lorsqu'ils ont
des difficultés et il est important et
quand vous parliez aussi de la la
capacité des des maires à agir il est
important au-delà de de de ces questions
de statut que les maires retrouvent
cette capacité à agir et à répondre
directement à leurs concitoyens et ne
pas avoir à dire que c'est pas dans leur
compét c'est que ça se passe ailleurs
voilà je pense que ça c'est fondamental
pour nous tous vous le savez vous avez
rappelé ce qui se produit
aujourd'hui c'est certain que ce mandat
là quand vous avez vous disiez quand
faut-il je pense qu'il y a urgence parce
que ce mandat est quand même très
particulier on a tous démarré un mandat
avec des équipes qui ne pouvaient pas
être installé euh là pour ça cette
circonstance pour la vie d'équipe a été
assez dramatique et durablement
dramatique je pense quand on voit les
démissions je pense que c'est aussi la
conséquence du démarrage de cette façon
des mandats et et ce mandat je trouve
aussi est percuté par cette évolution
sociétale qui fait que on est très
individualiste le collectif est en train
de disparaître si on y prend pas
garde on est individualiste on a
beaucoup de peine à imaginer qu'on peut
être responsable de ce qui nous arrive
il faut forcément trouver quelqu'un
d'autre qui soit responsable et puis on
assiste euh moi j'appelle ça la la
montée de l'irrespect de l'autorité
c'est-à-dire que voilà il y a une règle
mais pourquoi s'applique-t-elle à moi et
pourquoi celui qui est chargé de la
faire appliquer s'acharne-t-il justement
à la faire appliquer et on est confronté
à ça tous les jours et les conséquences
factuelles ce sont les agressions ce
sont les démissions voilà et c'est vrai
que à la MF on a été particulièrement
ému par cette bah l'évolution de ce
mandat et que dès euh finalement dès le
début David Lisnard nous a confié à
Frédéric rig et à moi-même la charge
d'animer de de je serais tenté dire de
revitaliser ce groupe de travail qui
existait antérieurement mais c'est vrai
que là la les circonstances faisaient
que il était beaucoup plus prignant
d'avancer et d'avancer vite sur les
réflexions au sein de ce groupe de
travail alors ce groupe de travail il
comporte 61 inscrits c'est dire la
l'intérêt que portent nos collègues à
cette réflexion je les en remercie
d'ailleurs parce que beaucoup nous ont
apporté des témoignages et la
préoccupation que nous avons c'est
effectivement de préserver l'engagement
à la gestion de la cité c'est aussi de
faire en sorte que nos collègues
puissent mieux concilier vie
professionnelle et mandat on a quand
même eu des témoignages poignants he de
collègues qui étai carrément en train de
se faire licencier parce qu'on leur
demandait de choisir entre leurs
absences pour exercer leur mand et leur
carrière professionnelle on a vu aussi
des collègues qui se trouvaient en
difficulté parce qu'ils avaient choisi
de travailler à temps partiel pour
libérer suffisamment de temps pour
exercer leur mandat et qui se trouvaient
en difficulté financière voilà donc avec
des répercussions sur leur famille et
puis on a vu plus récemment les maères
qui ont été agressé et je trouve enfin
je pense que tout le monde fait le même
constat ces formes d'agression elles
sont d'une part plus nombreuses mais en
plus elles elles concernent la vie
personnelle des élus qui jusqu'à jusquà
maintenant n'était pas le cas on
arrivait à se faire agresser si on
faisait une réflexion à quelqu'un dans
la rue ou autre là on s'attaque à la vie
personnelle des élus donc je pense que
c'est ce sont des circonstances qui font
qu'il faut assurer les élus dans leur
dans leur mandat et c'est ce qui a fait
l'objet de de la réflexion de notre
groupe de travail et puis nous avions
une autre préoccupation aussi mais vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente c'est la
diversification aussi des du profil des
élus tant du point de vue de l'âge que
du point de vue de l'origine
professionnelle on a on a on a des
catégories professionnels qui sont sous
représentés aujourd'hui parmi les élus
et puis ben nous sommes un certain
nombre d'élus retraités qui sont sur
représenter parce que la difficulté
d'exercice de nos mandats nécessite à la
fois d'y consacrer beaucoup plus de
temps que ce qu'on a peut-être pu
connaître dans le passé plus de temps
parce que les dossiers sont beaucoup
plus complexes
je pense qu'il y a un élément aussi de
la complexité
administrative mais vous en avez parlé
et je pense que votre délégation et
vous-même en êtes parfaitement conscient
c'est un vrai souci pour péréniser pour
conforter les maires pour éviter cette
usure il y a une très très grande
complexité qui va croissant on a une
nécessité de présence accrue avec la
présence dans l'intercommunalité alors
c'est pas une critique c'est un constat
c'est-à-dire que le maire est présent
dans sa commune il gère les dossiers de
sa commune et benah il est membre de
l'intercommunalité et il doit gérer des
dossiers aussi au sein de
l'intercommunalité en fait ça ça double
le temps de présence la plupart du temps
donc B n nos collègues sont pour
certains d'entre eux confrontés à cette
nécessité d'interrompre leur activité
professionnelle et y compris dans les
petites communes bon je suis également
président de l'association départemental
des maires de mon département et lorsque
j'échange avec mes collègues y compris
dans des très petites commune il y a pas
très longtemps j'ai changé avec un
collègue qui est agriculteur il me dit
ben moi je j'exploite seul donc j'ai été
obligé de recruter quelqu'un parce que
je ne peux plus m'occuper de mon
exploitation je dois consacrer un temps
suffisant à l'exercice de mon mandat
donc on voit bien aussi que cette
évolution de la complexité elle a eu
l'incidence sur le temps de présence des
élus sur leur investissement et vous
l'avez évoqué aussi madame la Présidente
sur la nécessité de formation c'estàdire
que les élus puissent se former on l'a
vu bah je peux prendre l'exemple concret
hein de mon association départementale
où malgré le covid nous avons maintenu
les formations des élus en début de
mandat en présentiel pour qu'il se
retrouveent pas tout seul alors bon on a
fait distance masque et tout ce qu'il
fallait et mais simplement toutes nos
formations ont été largement suivies et
très bien suivies par notamment les
nouveaux élus mais aussi par des élus
qui avaient déjà de l'expérience
puisqu'on est souvent confronté à une
évolution constante de la réglementation
et de la législation et bien il faut
bien euh effectivement être informé et
et pouvoir agir en conséquence donc
cette formation elle est fondamentale
elle est fondamentale aussi pour
permettre aussi bah il y a une vie après
les mandats pour ceux qui interromprent
leur activité professionnelle pour
retrouver une activité professionnel et
c'est un élément aussi qui est important
c'est de pouvoir valoriser ce qu'on
acquiert comme compéten et comme
connaissance à dans l'exercice d'un
mandat pour pouvoir les valoriser dans
le volet professionnel donc tous ces
tous ces éléments bon ont conduit B aux
propositions qui ont été largement
diffusé du groupe de travail
euh je voulais saluer l'engagement des
membres du du groupe de travail dire que
finalement on est arrivé à une
soixantaine de propositions c'est dire
que il y a beaucoup de sujets sur les
lesquel il faut s'attarder dans le ce
qu'on appelle de manière tout à fait
imprpre effectivement le statut parce
qu'on est surtout pas sur un registre de
de de de statut en tout cas
d'emploi et sur 12 domaines
d'amélioration et ce que je voulais
indiquer en ce dans ce propos
préliminaire c'est que la question des
indemnités parce que c'est de ça que
nous allons parler ce matin c'est
simplement un des champ d'amélioration
que nous souhaitons c'est-à-dire que
c'est pas le champ essentiel je pense
que c'est important de le préciser je
connais aucun élu qui ait brigué un
mandat en raison de l'indemnité
d'ailleurs ce serait une lourde erreur
parce que ça ne permet pas de vivre en
tout cas c'est
certain je connais aucun élu qui
continue son mandat parce qu'il y a une
indemnité mais c'est bien souvent parce
qu'il n'y a pas de relève dans dans
l'équipe et donc je pense bien qu'il est
est nécessaire de de resituer hein cette
cette question des indemnités à leur
juste place cela dit à la à la lueur de
l'exemple que je cité de l'élu
agriculteur euh l'exercice du mandat ne
peut pas conduire à un appauvrissement
de la personne
euh surtout si on veut diversifier les
tranches d'âge parce que quand on est
retraité on n' pas véritablement ce
souci par contre celui qui doit
interrompre une activité professionnelle
et bien s'il a une famille à faire vivre
euh même si son conjoint à une activité
professionnelle je il peut pas non plus
euh se permettre de de s'appauvrir et
d'avoir une situation financière qui se
dégrade donc je pense que dans enfin
sous cet angle-là c'est important euh
d'évoquer cette
question et je vous en
remercie souitezvous madame euh la vice
président nous faire une présentation
rapide des différents champs pour que
les collègues et aussi aussi au-delà des
des indemnités des choses et puis après
je passerai la parole peut-être d'abord
à mes deux
corapporteurs sur le sur le volet
indemnité donc François bonhomme Éric
rouge merci Madame les président de de
me permettre de les citer j'ai pas osé
le faire je pas comme ça ça nous donne
une vue exhaustive même si on s'attarde
plus précisément sur un BCI donc les
champs concernent à la fois les le la
conciliation de la vie de l'activité
professionnelle et l'exercice du mandat
je crois que ça c'est vraiment important
moi dans mon conseil municipal j'ai de
jeunes élus qui ont une activité
professionnelle sincèrement il n'y
arrivent pas il n'arrivent pas à avoir
suffisamment de présence l'un par
exemple était adjoint et m'a demandé de
devenir conseiller délégué parce qu'il
ne pouvait véritablement pas se
consacrer suffisamment de temps à son
mandat donc je pense que ça il faut si
on veut avoir cette diversité de profil
il faut véritablement que ce soit
conciliable
euh il y a un champ aussi d'amélioration
de la protection sociale des élus locaux
euh peut-être rappeler aussi que celui
qui interrompt son activité
professionnelle quelque part ses
cotisation retraite se trouve un peu
mise entre parenthèses et il y a une vie
et il y a une retraite après les mandats
donc je pense qu'il faut l'intégrer euh
il y a aussi un volet de valorisation
des élus engagés dans la vie locale euh
en améliorant leur retraite leur
retraite personnelle de se dire bah
est-ce que cet engagement dans la vie
locale peut pas aboutir à des
bonifications par exemple hein c'est pas
le seul la seule solution mais en tout
cas çaen est une faciliter l'accès à la
formation et la reconversion
professionnelle des élus locaux on vient
de le dire mais c'est vraiment
fondamental on peut pas se permettre de
se dire que fin de mandat
viiennent que poura je pense qu'il faut
véritablement l'envisager et et puis la
formation en cours de mandat on le voit
bien elle est fondamentale puisquon a
quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'évolutions législatives et c'est
important que les élus puissent les
suivre même ceux qui ont des services je
pense que c'est important que l'élu
conserve sa place d'orientation
politique de sa collectivité voilà et
donc le sujet d'amélioration des
conditions financière et fiscale de
l'exercice du
mandat la question aussi d'élargir la
protection fonctionnel des élus locaux
la question aussi de renforcement de la
sécurité des élus locaux face aux
agressions on constate une évolution
positive bon déjà dans les les les les
projets de texte hein sur le
renforcement des peines je pense aussi
que des directives ont dû être
données dans le département où je suis
élu une nouvelle procureure vient arrivé
nous avons fait Association des Maires
une réunion avec la procureur et les
élus et véritablement elle a pris des
engagements très forts vis-à-vis des
élus en disant que aucune plainte ne
serait classée sans suite que les élus
serit effectivement informé des suites
alors c'est l'application de notre droit
sauf qu'on sait tous très bien que ce
n'était pas appliqué euh et
véritablement elle a mis à disposition
mais je pense que beaucoup de procureurs
l'ont fait des élus une adresse mail de
telle manière que les élus puisse la
contacter directement et non seulement
ils le font mais elle répond donc je
pense que s'il y a eu une une évolution
cela dit je pense que c'est important
que il soit envoyé comme message à nos
concitoyens qu'agresser un élu c'est
juste pas possible donc je pense que de
temps en temps alors on sait que les
magistrats du siège sont libres de leur
décision je crois que de temps en temps
il faut véritablement que les agresseurs
voit que les sanctions peuvent tomber et
tomber lourdement je pense que c'est
important ça donne de la sérénité dans
les exercice des mandats on a eu on a vu
dans nos mandats une une évolution très
positive des relations entre la
gendarmerie et les élus hein il y a
vraiment des relations très proches les
gendarmes viennent viennent prendre nos
plaines dans les mairies maintenant il y
a eu des évolutions notables cela dit
maintenant il y a besoin de sécuriser
les élus moi quand je circule sur le
territoire certains élus me disent oui
mais non moi je vais pas porter plainte
parce que j'ai peur parce que comme il
se passera rien par contre il va y avoir
et mon nom et mon adresse dans la
plainte voilà donc je pense que c'est il
faut véritablement se pencher sur cette
question pour que les élus soient
sécurisés mais effectivement voilà
encourager aussi l'engagement des
étudiants et des jeunes actifs bon les
jeunes actifs on vient de le dire sur la
conciliation activité professionnelle et
mandat sur l'engagement des étudiants je
pense que on a évoqué beaucoup la
question des frais de déplacement pour
qu'il puissent puisque forcément les
étudiants vont étudier ailleurs que dans
nos petites communes je pense qu'il y a
même plus de choses à revoir puisque il
y a certains secteurs où on facilite les
absences si j'ai bien compris ce n'est
pas le cas des étudiants qui ne peuvent
pas s'absenter des travaux dirigés par
exemple pour aller à un conseil
municipal soutenir l'engagement des
parents et des personnes en situation de
handicap ou d'invalidité soutenir
l'engagement des parents ben ça renvoie
aussi à la question des frais de garde
bon on a eu une
avancée avec la loi engagement et
proximité mais je pense qu'il faut que
ce soit élargi parce que il y a pas que
le conseil municipal dans le travail des
élus euh notamment avec la montée en
puissance des intercommunalité on a
beaucoup d'élus qui n'ont pas forcément
de délégation mais qui siègent dans des
commissions à l'intercommunalité et je
pense qu'il faut élargir beaucoup les
commissions pour lesquelles un élu peut
se faire rembourser des frais de garde
de d'enfant assouplir aussi les
justificatifs à fournir parce qu'en zone
rurale on n' pas forcément un service de
garde d'enfant donc c'est ça peut être
aussi le jeune étudiant d'à côté qu'on
va indemniser enfin voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut faut assouplir et faire
confiance aux élus mais que ce soit bien
lié à une à une réunion de travail
effectivement je pense qu'il faut
vraiment l'élargir et puis favoriser que
le budget des des communes soit mieux
compensé c'est-à-dire que on puisse
effectivement rembourser ces frais de
garde et dans n'importe quelle commune
parce qu'en fait voilà on a on a des
difficultés à mobiliser les les élus qui
ont les charges familiales quelle que
soit la taille de la commune he c'est
pas propre à la taille de de la commune
et puis euh renforcer aussi l'assurance
des élus locaux je pense que ça euh
c'est important également et puis
garantir le respect des des droits des
élux locaux et l'effectivité des mesures
qui seront applicables parce que parfois
on prend un certain nombre de mesures et
on s'aperçoit que dans la la pratique
effectivement l'application est beaucoup
plus compliquée donc voilà les les axes
que l'on a euh dégagé par rapport aux
conditions d'exercice des mandats il y a
des axes aussi qui sont dégagés sur
l'assouplissement du fonctionnement des
conseils municipaux on a tous des
questions de quorum avec la voilà mi
mandat c'est une question qui se pose à
beaucoup d'élus donc je vois bon c'est
des choses qu'il faut pouvoir
assouplir je pense que ça n'empêchera
pas la qualité du fonctionnement des des
communes l'important pour nos
concitoyens c'est que les élus puissent
agir et que la commune continue à bien
jouer son
rôle euh voilà et puis bon la la place
du maire dans les décisions qui sont
prises sur son territoire je crois que
c'est important puisque avec l'évolution
de la législation bon il y a des
décisions qui sont prises ailleurs je
c'est très important que les élus euh
soient consultter il soit associé puisse
éventuellement avoir un droit de véau je
crois que c'est important euh on a on a
souligné l'importance pour le
développement des zones par exemple de
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables que ce soit bien au maire
qu'on demande de se prononcer je crois
que c'est très important ils sont
attachés à leur territoire ils ont bien
raison parce que leur conitoyens le sont
aussi voilà l'ensemble des des éléments
des champs que nous avons visité au
travers de ce groupe de travail et cela
à la fois à partir du témoignage des
collègues et j'ai remercie ceux qui ont
accepté de témoigner parce que pour
certains c'était difficile j'en ai bien
j'en ai bien eu conscience et puis bah à
la faveur aussi de tous les dossiers
qu'on a à traiter à la MF et puis dans
les associations départementales bien
sûr merci merci beaucoup euh madame la
vice-présidente voilà de de se d'avoir
balayé de manière aussi synthétique et
efficace le champ de vos travaux avant
de passer la parole à vos collègues je
dirais juste deux choses sur la
protection fonctionnelle des élus donc
nous avions effectivement après le décès
du maire de signe donc nos première
préoccupation remonte à
2019 dans la loi décideré de
dispositions sur la relation entre la
justice et notamment le procureur et les
élus parce que ce sont deux mondes qui
s'ignore au sens où euh on va dire les
acteurs de la justice ne connaissent pas
et qu'il y avait même parfois un relent
de défiance par rapport aux élus et que
nous avions dans cette loi qui remonte
un peu maintenant euh contraint en
quelque sorte le garde d'essau euh à à
rédigé des circulaires à destination des
procureurs pour
effectivement articuler un lien très
fort avec les élus comme le fait très
bien la gendarmerie et a donné des
éléments de suivi des choses bon alors
il se trouve que la garde des saut de
l'époque est partie vers d'autres cieux
le nouveau garde des saau est arrivé et
il y a eu un peu de de
latence sur la rédaction des circulaires
nous avons reçu à la délégation le garde
des saau en lui disant que nous
exercions une filature bienveillante
mais exigeante de la mise en œuvre de
ces disposition il nous a présenté à
l'époque département par département les
initiatives des procureurs le procureur
de duner qui était assez exemplaire et
que on voit bien aujourd'hui alors je
sais pas comment c'est chez les
collègues mais moi dans mon département
comme chez vous il y a des réunions qui
ont été organisé à l'initiative des
procureurs avec les sous-préfets euh la
police et et la gendarmerie que des
numéros se mettent en place et que je
pense que chacun a pris conscience après
les nombreuses et violentes agressions
de de cette année que bon là
effectivement on était sur l'effectivité
des mesure et que c'était très important
alors sur la protection fonctionnelle
des élus nous en avons parlé récemment
parce qu'il a une proposition de loi qui
a permis d'aligner les peines possibles
pour des agressions d'élus sur cell en
vigueur pour les agressions à l'encontre
de personnes titulaires de en dépositair
d'une autorité donc les gens là M P donc
c'est parfait et nous avons demandé
l'élargissement de la protection
fonctionnelle à tous les élus d'un
conseil municipal parce que même si vous
n'êtes pas ma et adjoint ou conseiller
municipal délégué dans vos communes un
conseiller municipal est identifié parce
qu'il est conseiller municipal et vous
avez un citoyen qui est pas content de
de de je ne sais quoi qui qui va pas
aller s'exliquer qui que ce soit mais il
va interpeller parfois d'une manière
agressive l'élu et on a vu des
agressions sur des élus qui étaient
conseillers municipaux et donc nous nous
avons demandé l'élargissement à tous les
élus municipaux y compris à l'opposition
quand je dis tout le monde bon et que
alors au Sénat nous n'avons pas pu le
faire parce qu'il existe une arme
nucléaire qui est l'article 40 alors
tant mieux d'un côté ça veut dire qu'on
n pas le drit de contraindre des
collectivités à des dépenses
supplémentaires donc nous on n'a pas pu
euh le faire c'était une proposition
transpartisan tous les groupes portai ça
et donc nous avons en quelque sorte
donner une injonction aimable mais très
exigeante à la ministre des
collectivités en disant il n'y a que
l'État qui peut lever le gage et que moi
il me semble que si
l'état vraiment veut aujourd'hui
affirmer et reconnaître
l'importance de l'engagement et et la
nécessité de l'engagement des élus
locaux là il faut y aller voilà donc ça
c'était le point puis dernier point
quand vous dites que les maires doivent
être associés les élus les élus associé
aux choses qui les concernent et que
souvent ils vont devoir payer ici on a
un principe simple au Sénat qui décide
paye et à minima celui qui paye doit
être associé et nous avons sur la loi
travail un dernier exemple très récent
où il y a un article 10 dans cette loi
travail où où on dit que les communes
doivent présenter un schéma de la petite
enfance et qu'au départ part du texte en
gros l'élu il était sous la menace du
fouet parce que si le président de
département et le préfet trouvait que
c'était insuffisant on le mettait en
demeure de et que aujourd'hui aucun élu
local n'est associé dans les conseils
d'administration de la CAE nationale
d'allocation familiale ou dans la caiss
départementale moi j'ai encore eu hier
un courrier d'un maire qui me dit que la
C vient de lui expliquer que le
personnel qu'il avait n'avait pas la
qualification théorique nécessaire sauf
que les gens sont parfaits et lui la
personne d'autre et donc la cave lui met
en place des injonctions qui sont
contradictoires avec l'exigence de
service donc j'ai vu que la MF en
parlait moi j'ai posé une question
récemment au gouvernement disant ça ça
n'est plus
possible cher collègue corapporteur
mieur bonhomme et
kou
bien merci beaucoup madame la la
présidente merci beaucoup madame la
vice-présidente de votre de votre
intervention B en fait il y a une grande
partie des thèmes que vous avez évoqué
qui se recouvrent avec le les soucis de
cette de cette délégation avant avant
d'aborder la la question indemnitaire en
tant que telle peut-être revenir sur
l'ensemble des éléments que que vous
avez que vous avez balayé la vraie
difficulté et je pense qu'on peut la
résumer de cette façon là c'est que
euh être élu c'est pas un un métier
c'est un choix c'est un choix qu'on fait
à un moment c'est un choix qu'on fait à
un moment donné la vraie question c'est
que il ne faut pas que ce choix d'une
quelconque façon que ce soit altère ou
la trajectoire personnelle ou la
trajectoire professionnelle pour faire
le plus simple
possible peu et de moins en moins d'élus
en fait seront élus à vie d'ailleurs je
suis pas sûr qu'il faut qu'il faille le
souhaiter euh puisque bon ça c'est notre
la question le cumul dans le temps est
un autre est un autre débat mais enfin
c'est une c'est une c'est une question
et il faut faire en sorte que cette
situation des élus ne soit pas
désincitativ alors je m'explique de de
de la manière la plus simple possible si
c'est un morceau si être élu local avoir
des responsabilités notamment pour les
exécutifs est un morceau de la carrière
professionnelle alors il faut que
celle-ci puisse être valorisée dans le
temps ça veut dire effectivement vous
l'avez rappelé de la formation ça veut
dire aussi que je le répète souvent la
plupart des élus notamment ceux qui ont
eu des fonctions exécutive que ça soit
adjoint vice-président maire président
enfin l'ensemble des postes où on a une
délégation je dis pas que les autres ne
font rien je dis simplement que la
spécialisation est plus forte quand on
apportter une délégation quelle qu'elle
soit de conseiller municipal délégué
jusqu'à jusqu'à président
et bien entendu moi et je pense que
c'est vrai pour l'ensemble des collègues
on sait une chose c'est que quand on est
élu on apprend plein de choses la
plupart du temps assez rapidement
d'ailleurs mais on apprend on apprend
plein de choses et il serait normal il
serait normal que ce qui est appris soit
valorisé et valorisable de quelque façon
que ce soit par une valorisation
automatique des acquis de l'expérience
c'est possible mais ce n'est pas
automatique par une version diplômante
aussi
de qu'on aurait automatiquement parce
que justement on a été élu il faut que
le fait d'être élu ne soit pas considéré
comme un frein mais au contraire ouvre
des perspectives et insérer en gros le
moment de l'élection le moment de la
carrière élective dans une carrière
personnelle et professionnelle et c'est
ça le plus important ça veut dire aussi
et vous l'avez rappelé qu'il faut
entourer d'une certaine façon l'exercice
du mandat électif que ça soit par des
choses très TER à terre comme
effectivement la garde la garde d'enfant
peut-être les remboursements des frais
de des frais de déplacement quand il
s'agit de déplacement officiel et que
les élus n'hésitent pas à le demander
parce que c'est mal vu c'est mal perçu
et on arrive enfin et pour finir et pas
être trop long à la question à la
question indemnitaire alors bon deux
points un point général et un point
personnel sur le point général nous
travaillons avec François bonhom et la
présidente Gatel sur la question des des
indemnités et il y a manifestement des
des
voies d'amélioration des voies
d'amélioration qui dépendent des élus
mais pas que
euh sur un
travail universitaire que j'ai pu
réaliser on montre nettement que dans
les communes de moins de 1000 habitants
dans les communes de moins de 500
habitants de fait l'indemnité n'est
qu'un chiffre théorique pour les mares
qui ne peuvent pas se l'octroyer ou
choisissent de ne pas se l'octroyer pour
faire pour en faire autre chose et que
la la fameuse dotation des d'État est
manifestement insuffisante en la matière
en l'espèce et on se félicite toujours
en ce qui nous concerne et je pense que
c'est global s'agissant des Français on
se félicite donc de ce cadrillage
démocratique qui est une SP spécificité
française et qui est assurée sur les les
les territoires on doit être le seul
pays où au moment des élections on
arrive à mobiliser 1 million de
personnes sur un corps électoral de 47
millions c'est une richesse démocratique
si on veut pas d'épuisement comme on le
voit on le voit actuellement bah il faut
faire il faut faire des choses et l'État
doit prendre doit prendre sa part parce
qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'on est bien
content que les élus soient là euh et
donc qu'il coûte en fait
structurellement moins cher que si on
les remplacé par des fonctionnaires on
peut pas dire ça et ne pas en prendre
les conséquences et c'est
malheureusement ce qui ce qui se passe
alors on peut adapter on peut on peut
transformer la logique indemnitaire mais
je finis sur un point qui est pas
partagé et qui m'est personnel mais que
je veux quand même
redétailler je pense qu'à un moment
donné pour certaines
fonctions la logique indemnitaire n'est
plus à même de rendre compte de ce que
vit tel ou tel élu je m'explique
quand je met à part la la question des
retraités mais on pourra y revenir parce
que c'est un lien avec ce qu'on c'est un
lien avec ce qu'on va c'est un lien avec
ce que je dis parce que au bout d'un
moment la demande ou plus exactement les
exigences liées au mandat font que et
bien ça spécifie ou ça caractérise ou ça
aide une certaine partie de la
population pour exercer ses mandats
parce que les autres ne peuvent pas le
faire et je suis bien content et comme
tout le monde qu'il y ait des des
retraités au poste de décision locale
mais on peut regretter qu'il soit
surreprésenté à ce point par rapport à
la population française maintenant en
disant ça je me méfie parce que un jour
on arrive tous à la retraite doncut
quand même faire attention aux propos
qu'on tient mais tout à fait tout à fait
sérieusement sur il y a une question
quand même la question c'est que quand
l'activité élective se substitue de
manière complète à l'activité
professionnelle ou rend impossible
l'activité professionnelle alors je ne
crois pas je ne crois plus que
l'indemnité soit suffisante je pense
qu'il faut aboutir à un autre type de à
un autre type de contrat qui ne soit pas
un contrat professionnel mais qui soit
un contrat qui soit limité dans le temps
mais qui donne les mêmes avantages que
ce qu'on pourrait avoir par ailleurs une
fois qu'on a ça ça ne peut concerner que
certains ça ne peut concerner que
certains élus et dans l'attente je crois
qu'il y a des adaptations qui sont qui
sont nécessaires que nous allons que
nous allons porter et je finis juste sur
sur un point moi j'ai j'ai alors
peut-être que chachudé craint l'eau
froide et puis c'est moi qui le dit ça
sera pas Françoise Gatel donc ça sera
forcément mieux vu j'ai j'ai une petite
crainte
oui j'ai une petite crainte par rapport
à la débauche de la débauche de
consultation actuelle autour du statut
de l'élu qu'il y ait des exercices
collectifs que ça se passe bien c'est
une très c'est une très bonne c'est une
très bonne chose mais à force de à force
de
de de parler avec beaucoup de de
partenaires j'ai peur qu'une partie de
ces partenaires soi déçu parce que les
demandes sont hétérogène que elles
émergent de tous les côtés que la
situation des élus n'est pas forcément
comparable et
j'espère j'espère que les propositions
gouvernementales qui pourraient être
fait seront à la hauteur des attentes
qui sont suscitées mais comme vous le
comprenez dans mes propos j'ai un doute
non pas existentiel mais un doute tout
court
voilà merci madame la Présidente ben
dans le même fil de de ce que qui vient
de
direouche d'abord vous dire que je n'ai
pas grand-chose à plutôt je souscris
globalement et très largement à à vos
propos en tout cas sur les conditions
d'exercice aujourd'hui des des élus qui
posent certain nombre de limites et de
questions nouvelle aussi parce que
Ben la fonction d'élu a considérablement
changé alors il y a des éléments
structurels des éléments conjoncturel
mais globalement d'abord on constate que
la durée
d'engagement civique des des élus a
tendance à se réduire on a plus des des
mandats comme à saint-chamon à de 48 ans
quand il y avait Antoine Pinet donc
c'est c'est peut-être le signe de de
aussi des changements d'évolution de la
part des administrés mais aussi des élus
hein qui le changement sociétal touche
aussi les élus et puis il y a des
interactions entre les deux forcément
euh ensuite
sur le le mandat je le considère
évidemment dans l'absolu dans globalité
c'estàdire dire avant le mandat parce
que tout le monde a été euh à une vie
avant d'être élu j'allais dire et avait
une certaine représentation des choses
et tout le monde sait et en tout cas ici
que l'exercice du mandat et des
responsabilités produit des changements
profond dans la vision de des choses de
la façon de conduire son mandat et de la
vision globale de la société et puis
aussi après le mandat parce que vous
avez évoqué SME de de frein difficulté
c'est-à-dire la sortie du mandat et ça
c'est vrai que c'est un point parfois
impensé de de de l'action de l'action
publique alors après on rentre
rapidement sur les les les vois et
moyens pour essayer de de de traiter ces
questions là alors on on on on se pinche
là peu sur la question du régime
indemnitaire comme vous l'avez très bien
dit il faut pas s'en tenir là mais notre
question c'est de voir comment on peut
améliorer le régimeitaire de la telle
sorte qu'il soit qu' neutralise les
questions de cet ordre là précisément
que ça ne soit plus une question or
aujourd'hui pour ensemble de catégories
d'élu qui été évoqué c'est une question
parce que ça crée des difficultés soit
d'ordre professionnel soit dans
l'exercice courant de son mandat crédit
d'absence
enfin crédit d'heure et et autorisation
euh
ensuite une une des voix qui qui me
paraît intéressante c'est savoir si
pour l'après de la même manière comme il
a été question lors de la discussion sur
les retraites pour les sapeurs pompés
volontaes on pourrait pas envisager une
bonification d'engagement civique enfin
on l'appelle comme on veut mais je
préfère civique à citoyen c'est
tellement devenu galvodé que citoyen que
civique je trouve que ça ça ça c'est un
côté Romain qui me convient mais bon ça
c'est chacun voit cette façon mais en
tout cas voilà avoir uneesèce de
continuité une vision globale des choses
sur sur ceux qui ont eu ou l'audace ou
de de devenir élu et et et de faire en
sorte que on valorise les acquis de
l'expérience parce que c'est vrai que la
fonction d'élus on est on est apprenant
sur le tas mais on est apprenant dans un
temps réduit aussi et dans cette
catégorie d'élus je distinguerais quand
même les élus municipaux je pense quefin
je m'adresse c'est pas un propos de
circonstance mais
euh on n' pas vraiment de question sur
l'indemnité des élus régionaux ou même
despart
aux je pense que c'est pas en tout cas
le c'est pas en tout cas le l'élément
essentiel par contre sur les élus
municipaux oui et il se fait que le
mandat municipal je le considère comme
le mandat essentiel en France avec le
mandat présidentiel euh et c'est
simplement la traduction d'une
visibilité chez chaque citoyen qui ne
connaît que deux types d'élus grosso
modo ces élus municipaux et
singulièrement la figure du maire et
l'élu présidentiel bon l' li
présidentiel c'est notre question donc
voilà donc n nos questions effectivement
c'est comment l'État aussi dans sa part
va traduire budgétairement et
financièrement les moyens de
euh favoriser et de lisser les
difficultés et les irritants que l'on
peut avoir en tant que du point de vue
indemnitaire je parle et la dpel me
paraît quand même l'élément essentiel
voilà je sais que vous avez fait déjà
des des propositions dans ce sens je
pense qu'elles sont largement
convergentes mais comme on a beaucoup de
déclarations d'amour régulièrement et
singulièrement au moment du Congrès des
Maires je pense que ça sera aussi un
moment opportun pour pour le traduire
dans les faits parce que comm chacun
sait les preuv d'amour sont au moins
aussi importantes que les
déclarations voilà donc nous on est très
en tout cas on est très attentif aux
propositions de la MF et et pour grande
partie je pense que on aura des des
propositions largement
convergentes merci François alors je je
propose peut-être madame la
vice-présidente si vous êtes ok de
répondre à cette première série question
ensuite il y a deux autres demandes de
prise de parole donc notre collègue
Bernard Bui et notre collègue
Anne-Catherine
Loisier merci Madame la la présidente
eu sur la sur la la première
intervention enfin il y a des il y a des
éements convergents sur les deux
interventions effectivement le le mandat
municipal c'est un mandat très
particulier et le plus important je je
je je vous rejoins pour ma part j'ai
c'est aussi un mandat départemental et
c'est pas du tout la même chose
l'engagement des conseillers municipaux
est beaucoup plus important parce que
d'abord ils sont ils sont dans leur
village ils sont dans leur commune ils
croisent leurs concitoyens tous les
jours et ils sont interpellés tous les
jours je pense que c'est vraiment c'est
la collectivité de proximité c'est pour
ça qu'il faut la défendre à la fois dans
ses dans ses compétences et dans sa dans
son existence et dans sa
protection sur le le ce qui a été évoqué
par Monsieur le Sénateur kerouche
eu je crois que la fonction d'élu c'est
quand même bien différent euh de d'une
d'une forme de fonctionnarisation je
pense que vraiment on le voit tous les
jours mais je pense que vous y êtes
aussi confrontés parce que je pense que
tous les élus ils sont confrontés on a
vraiment un rôle extrêmement différent
de nos équipes administrative par
exemple enfin je veux dire euh on
apporte autre chose on apporte une
impulsion et je pense que le
de transformer le mandat en une forme de
contrat il faudrait pas qu'on glisse
vers une forme de
professionnalisation parce qu'on l'a dit
tout à l'heure les mandats ont tendance
à se raccourcir alors c'est l'électeur
qui décide voilà je pense que ceux qu'
ont un mandat long ben leurs électeurs
ont jugé pertinent de leur accorder des
des mandats successifs mais quoi qu'il
en soit euh ça ça peut pas euh se
prolonger au travers d'e d'une forme de
statut ou de de professionnalisation
donc il faut trouver quelque chose je je
vous rejoins pour les les les les élus
qui mettent entre parenthèses leur vie
professionnelle cela dit je pense que
véritablement il faut qu'on reste bien
des élus avec des fonctions d'élus de de
de de gouvernance d'orientation de de la
politique dans notre collectivité et
qu'on se retrouve pas alors c'est
peut-être pas ce que vous vouliez dire
mais en tout cas je voulais il il y a
certaines personnes qui préconisent
cette cette forme de fonctionnarisation
de de
professionnalisation à l'AMF on ne pense
pas que ce soit une une solution et en
tout cas moi je je je ne je n'y
souscrirai pas parce qu'on est on est un
tendem obligé entre les administratifs
quand on a la chance d'en avoir et nous
les élus mais c'est cette
complémentarité qui fait qu'on fait
avancer les les idées et les dossiers
donc pour sur ce point là sur la dpel
[Musique]
évidemment je crois
que madame la Présidente et et Monsieur
carou vous l'avez évoqué dans certaines
communes
effectivement malgré l'augmentation
théorique du montant des indemnités
elles n'ont pas été effectives parce que
les élus ont considéré que leurs budget
ne pouvait pas faire face à cette cette
augmentation ça pose ça pose un vrai
sujet de ce de ce choix de de de de se
faire attribuer ou non l'intégralité de
la de l'indemnité c'est compliqué sur le
terrain parce qu'en fait celui qui ne
prend pas son indemnité dans son
intégralité le fait pour bien faire dans
l'intérêt de sa commune mais en même
temps celui d'à côté qui prend son qui
qui accepte son indemnité du coup il bon
il se trouve dans une situation un peu
un peu particulière par rapport au choix
de son son voisin je crois que ce qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui dans les
discussions qu'on a c'est aussi la
capacité de la collectivité à
reconnaître l'engagement des élus alors
c'est vrai qu'il est peu connu cet
engagement mais quand on regarde je
pense que l'enquête du cvipof nous
dévoilera un certain nombre de
sujets cette enquête qui a été engagée
par conjointement par la MF et le et le
le le ministère des des collectivités
euh le temps de de de qu'un élu consacre
à son mandat c'est je crois queil
ressorait c'est au moyen de 32hur
c'est-à-dire c'est
quasiment un temps plein
euh je pense que nos concitoyens n'en
ont pas véritablement conscience parce
qu'en fait on travaille à la mairie mais
on travaille aussi chez nous parce que
le soir c'est là qu'on a du temps pour
pour préparer un certain nombre de
choses et puis quand la mairie est
fermée on continue à travailler ça se
voit pas forcément sauf quand il fait
nuit avec la lumière euh surgit mais
donc je veux dire c'est un
engagement constant ça vous l'avez tous
souligné parce que c'est tous les jours
ça s'arrête pas le weekend c'est un
engagement exigeant parce que on a à
cœur de restituer à ceux qui nous ont
élu la confiance qu'ils nous ont fait
euh mais je pense que là on est à un
stade
où Ben la
collectivité doit exprimer cette forme
de de alors je sais pas si c'est le si
le terme de reconnaissance est approprié
mais en tout cas de valoriser cet
engagement parce que c'est un véritable
engagement vous disiez je sais plus quel
terme vous avez employé moi je dis c'est
courage c'est du courage pour les les
gens qui s'engagent dans un mandat et
qui et qui poursuivent ce mandat c'est
un peu l'histoire des des démissions
qu'on connaît là durant ce mandat actuel
moi j'avais changé avec
ces comment dirais-je ces euh des
collègues dont dont des conseillers
municipaux ont démissionné entraînant
parfois d'ailleurs une réélection et et
qui me disait ben en fait ils sont même
pas venus me dire qu'ils n'étaiit pas
d'accord ils ont démissionné comme si on
pouvait rentrer sortir d'un mandat alors
que ce mandat c'est l'expression de la
confiance de nos de nos concitoyens et
là il y a quelque chose qui est pas
intégré enfin qui me semble-t-il et donc
je dis c'est du courage de de de
s'engager et de et de poursuivre les
mand parce qu'en fait il faut arriver à
à trancher sur certains sujets à
expliquer à nos concitoyens que tout
n'est pas forcément possible et là je
pense que c'est
euh cette cette question de la de la des
indemnités ça procède de ça aussi de
cette de ce retour de la collectivité
pour valoriser cet
engagement merci je passe la parole à
Bernard cher Bernard merci présidente
Madame la vice-présidente je sais pas si
ce que je vais dire est un constat que
vous partagez ou pas moi sur mon
territoire je suis élu de la drrome et
je suis conseiller départemental d'un
canton de 64 communes où il y a beaucoup
de petites communes rurales avec des
communes qui ont de 1 à 5000 habitants
pour la plus grosse le constat que je
fais c'est depuis quelques années j'ai
l'impression que la profession d'élu on
va dire ça comme ça a beaucoup évolué
puisqueaujourd'hui le constat c'est ce
que vous faites et ce qu'a fait mon
collègue Éric gauche on a de plus en
plus de retraités et en parallèle on a
aussi de plus en plus de fonctionnaires
donc les fonctionnaires qui sont élus en
du temps de libre parce qu'ils ont des
décharges ils ont la possibilité de
retrouver leur emploi à la fin et
aujourd'hui je vois une désaffection des
professions essentiellement libérales
des entrepreneurs qui aujourd'hui n'ont
pas le temps à consacrer et s'ils
consacre du temps très souvent ils
démissionnent au bout de 2 ou 3 ans
parce qu'ils se rendent compte que ce
n'est pas compatible avec leur métier et
que derrière ben ils ont leur entreprise
qui é florissante qui ne l'est plus
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus s'impliquer
autant qu'il faut donc à partir de ce
constat je me demande si on pourrait pas
travailler pour appliquer aux élus un
peu ce qu'on a mis en place dans
certains départements je sais qu'on l'a
fait dans la Drome des conventions avec
les entreprises qui mettent à
disposition le sapeur pompier donc qui
pourrait mettre à disposition l'élu un
certain nombre d'heures et qui derrière
s'engagerait à la fin du mandat à
récupérer à reprendre leur élu à temps
complet donc je pense que c'est une
piste qu'il faudrait qu'on travaille
parce que sinon on va avoir
une des élus qui vont être
essentiellement fonctionnaires et puis
retraités donc je pense que c'est pas
bon après en ce qui concerne les
indemnités euh chez nous j'ai moi je Mo
j'ai pas entendu remonter de problème
sur le montant des indemnités il faut
dire que l'augmentation qui a touché les
petites communes la dernière fois a
permis d'augmenter les des indemnités
pour les mares des petites communes
essentiellement alors après ils l'ont
pris ou l'ont pas pris c'est variable
d'une commune à l'autre parce que les
richesses d'une commune à l'autre sont
tout à fait variables moi j'ai des
petites communes qui ont 10 ou 15
habitants où le maire a pris la totalité
de l'indemnité parce que il avait les il
pouvait le faire ce qui est pas
forcément bien vu des communes qui ont 4
ou 500 habitants qui elles n'ont pas les
moyens pour octroyer donc on a
aujourd'hui une grosse disparité dans
les attributions d'indemnité avec la
nouvelle circulaire qui a été faite
enfit avec le nouvelle lois qui a été
voté il y a déjà quelques années et donc
aujourd'hui je pense que là-dessus il y
a un clivage qui se fait suivant la
richesse des communes où certains osent
le prendre et ça fait euh je veux dire
on est mal vu d'une commune à l'autre et
puis ça fait des ému aussi on le voit au
renouvellement électoral où dans
certaines communes les gens ben il y a
pas de Vivier et par contre d'autres
communes où il y a des gens qui veulent
faire une profession d'élu et qui
souhaitent être élu à vie parce que ça
leur permet de de de gagner leur vie et
c'est un bon complément donc y compris
dans des petites communes moi je je le
vois comme ça donc voilà aujourd'hui je
pense que là-dessus il faut qu'on
travaille sur ces indemnités voilà et
puis après sur la
formation je pense que beaucoup de
travail a été fait par les associations
des m exactement et vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure en début de mandat je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut vraiment qu'on
arrive à une validité derrière mon
collègue kouche l'a dit la validation
des acquis professionnels et je pense
qu'on a dans les entreprises il faut
qu'on arrive à plus le valoriser pour
que derrière l'élu qui a été maire je
veux dire n'importe quoi d'une commune
de 1000 ou 5000 habitants mais derrière
ils puissent accéder à des concours
administratifs ou autres ça pourrait
faire des passerelles aussi
intéressantes parce que ils ont quand
même bien
travaillé merci madame la présidente
Madame la vice-présidente alors un petit
peu en complément de de mes collègues
moi effectivement je je ne croise pas en
Côte d'Or d'élus qui me disent que les
indemnités ne sont pas assez élevé par
contre je croise beaucoup d'élus de
peties communes qui aimeraient bien
pouvoir prendre leurs indemnités mais
qui ne le font pas soit parce que leur
commune est dans une situation
financière qui ne le permet pas soit
parfois parce qu'il y a cette fameus
règles que je ne maîtrise pas bien mais
vous savez dans le calcul de la DPL sur
le potentiel fiscal ou financier qui
fait que de toutes petites communes euh
avec 1h 1h3 de secrè de mairie par
semaine donc le maire il passe ses
journées c'est lui qui fait le
fleurissement l'entretien de la voirie
et au final il ne peut pas prendre les
indemnités parce que avec cette règle
voilà de je sais plus si potentielle ou
financier ou fiscal il ne peut pas il
échappe à la dotation et donc le budget
de sa commune ne lui permet pas après il
y a un autre sujet moi qui mete beaucoup
dans la la disponibilité et l'engagement
des élus c'est quand même le fait d'être
confronté et vous l'avez évoqué à des
réalités à des compétences et des
responsabilités de plus en plus pesantes
et et
complexes voire on l'a vu
malheureusement dangereuse et notamment
au regard de l'urbanisme des compétences
relatives à l'urbanisme et quand j'en
j'évoque ces sujets avec eux ils meen
font aussi souvent par finalement pour
eux du du manque de relais au niveau de
l'intercommunalité une intercommunalité
qui on sait leur prend de plus en plus
de temps parfois les exaspères alors
quand on parle de formation moi ils me
disent beaucoup aussi avec le temps
qu'on passe maintenant dans les réunions
intercommunales et autres on a on trouve
plus le temps d'aller en plus se former
donc je pense que on ne peut pas
échapper à une réflexion aussi qui
intègre l'intercommunalité quand on
parle du des des élus municipaux parce
qu'elle prend une place en terme de
temps donc de plus en plus importante et
parfois et bien il semble qu'elle ne
répond pas à leur attente en terme
d'accompagnement technique de S soutient
dans l'exercice quotidien de de leur
fonction madame la madame la présidente
Madame madamees et Messieurs les les
sénateurs
[Musique]
euh euh et je serais tenté élu c'est pas
un métier c'est un engagement voilà je
pense que il faut qu'on le garde ça
parce que c'est ce qui fait notre valeur
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens après il
faut la valoriser cette valeur si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi il faut qu'ils ai
qu'ils en aient conscience mais je enfin
sincèrement je pense que notre
démocratie elle est vraiment assise sur
cet engagement euh alors citoyen ou on
l'appelle comme on veut en fait c'est
euh euh les élus euh ce sont les pères
de enfin ce sont des altteres égaux de
notre population et je pense que c'est
important que ça reste comme ça
c'est-à-dire que chaque citoyen peut
devenir un élu euh voilà donc je pense
pense que c'est ça il faut qu'on arrive
à le préserver par tout
moyen après la question des des
indemnités c'est une vraie question
financière des pour les budgets des
petites communes ça renvoie oui à une
compensation effective et effectivement
la dpel n'est pas ni adaptée ni
suffisante puisqu'elle couvre pas le
surcût pour les communes donc
effectivement c'est tout à fait à
l'honneur d' merère de dire mais moi je
peux pas parce que toute façon mon
budget peut pas supporter ce qui est pas
normal c'est qu'il soit c'est qu'il soit
confonté à cette situation là alors vous
dites j'entends pas d'élus qui disent
indemnités sont insuffisantes non c'est
vrai parce que on n pas on s'est pas
engagé dans les mandats pour aller dire
ça par contre quand on regarde très
concrètement les dépenses qu'engagent
les élus et quand on en parle j'allais
dire un petit peu en off et et de
manière assez spontanée avec eux et ils
arrivent très rapidement à nous dire bah
oui si je mets bout à bout tous mes
déplacements parce que dans un un
département rural les petites communes
c'est celles qui sont les plus loins de
de la ville cheflieu ils font autant de
déplacements que ceux qui sont juste
dans la dans la couronne de la ville
chef-lieu euh je citais tout à l'heure
l'agriculteur qui s'il veut exercer son
mandat comment dirais-je va devoir
prendre un salarié pour faire son
travail sur son
exploitation et puis la charge elle est
vous l'avez souligné elle est différente
selon la taille des communes c'est vrai
mais elle est importante dans une petite
commune c'est vrai qu'on voit des maires
qui se retrouvent des fois agents
d'entretien municipaux parce qu'il y a
personne pour le faire et ils le font
mais dans des communes plus importantes
bah c'est la charge des des réunions
d'ailleurs qui incombe aussi au maires
des petites communes ça ça représente un
investissement très important alors sur
la question de
l'intercommunalité euh enfin je reviens
sur le fait on a un vrai problème sur
les dotations pour compenser les
l'indemnité des élus là ce qui renverra
sûrement à la question qui a été posée
de dire l'état pourra-t-il tenir ses
engagements parce que je pense qu'il
faudra quand même passer par berc et que
ça va certainement représenter un
exercice
compliqué
oui tout à fait exactement et il faut
vraiment que ce soit que ce soit revu
que ce soit mieux adapté à la
réalité la réalité des communes qu'elle
soit étendue aussi à plus de communes
parce que de toute façon elle est quand
même elle est quand même réservée à un
faible nombre de communes et sur la
gouvernance de
l'intercommunalité euh c'est vrai que
euh on a passé quelques décennies à
construire les
intercommunalités à mon sens
certainement trop grosse dans certaines
circonstances parce que du coup euh
beaucoup d'élus ne s'y retrouvent pas
mais on n'a pas du tout travaillé sur la
gouvernance des
intercommunalités et c'est certainement
pour cette raison qu'un certain nombre
d'élus
euh ne se retrouvent pas parce qu'en
fait l'intercommunalité c'est nous les
maires c'est pas c'est pas quelqu'un
d'autre c'est nous et ça c'est je pense
que il y a certainement à faire évoluer
cette gouvernance pour que chacun se
sente partie prenante de
l'intercommunalité et quand des élus
peuvent dire l'intercommunalité ne nous
aide pas je vais donner un exemple très
concret lorsque l'État s'est désengagé
de l'instruction des permis de
construire dans certaines
intercommunalités on s'est cotisé les
communes se sont cotisé parce que ça
ressemble à ça pour créer un service
d'instruction des dossiers et il m'est
arrivé d'échanger avec des élus en
disant mais oui mais alors là moi je
suis contraint ça m'échappe tu signe
quand même ton vous signez votre le
permis de construire oui mais mais et et
là c'est c'est là qu'en rediscutant on
se dit mais ce service de l'interco
c'est le service des élus on n pas enfin
voilà on a à travailler avec lui comme
un service de la commune mais je pense
que il y a oui il y a certainement à à à
continuer à faire évoluer cette relation
entre les communes et et
l'intercommunalité B dont l'existence
n'est pas n'est pas à remettre en cause
c'est pas le c'est pas le sujet mais
trouver des relation où ce soit gagnant
gagnant quoi que tout le monde il
retrouve son compte mais c'est vrai que
sur le terrain c'est une réalité ça oui
oui oui et du coup le fait qu'on nit pas
pu travailler sur cette gouvernance ça
contribue à l'isolement de certains
maères qui se sentent effectivement pas
forcément soutenu alors qu'en fait ce
serait possible que l'intercommunalité
apporte ce soutien
ici il suffit d'y
travailler je sais pas si j'ai balayé
les les questions que vous avez
évoqué merci beaucoup madame la
vice-présidente juste en écho à ce que
disent les collègues sur la dpel
effectivement avec les collègues Éric
kouche et françoisom on s'interroge sur
le sujet et on a deux questions c'est
est-ce qu'on élargit ou est-ce qu'on
étend la des PE à des strates de
communes supplémentaires et nous nous n
somm effectivement interrogés sur ce
qu'évoquait
Anne-Catherine l'intégration du
potentiel financier de la commune pour
être éligible il me semble alors Éric et
peut-être Bruno qui est notre
administrateur pourront être plus précis
que moi mais on a regardé il y a entre
85 et 88 % des communes éligibles à la
dpel qui le sont ça veut dire qu'il
resteraiit 10 10 % des communes
théoriquement éligibles qu' sont pas à
cause du potentiel financier mais on
regarde un peu cet élément là de la même
manière que nous sommes en train de
regarder un sujet en disant
amère il exerce des compétences de
l'État qui lui ont pas été transféré
c'estàd qu'il sont inhérent on va
prendre l'état civil on va prendre
l'urbanisme on va prendre l'organisation
des élections et nous nous sommes sur
une idée pour que l'État effectivement ù
la nation ne se contente pas de rendre
des hommages réguliers aux élus en
disant vous êtes formidables vous êtes
pas assez nombreux on voilà mais que
l'État affirme que comme il a besoin des
préfets des sous-préfets il a besoin des
élus locaux et que ceci c'est même enfin
ceci exerce à la place de l'État un
certain nombre de fonctions et nous
sommes en train de regarder l'idée de
dire
que pour toutes les communes peut-être
c'est à considérer il nous semble que
l'État devrait reconnaître ce rôle et
l'affirmer ce qui donnerait peut-être du
respect au aussi nos
concitoyens à la fonction exercée par
les élus ou un peu en tout cas c'est que
l'État devrait
contribuer peut-être pour toutes les
strates de communes enfin on en
discute un pourcentage des indemnité
globale versé pour pour être très
concret on pourrait se dire mais c'est
encore un exemple que 10 % des fonction
exercé par le maire le sont comme s'ils
étaient des agents de l'État et que les
état n'a pas employé des travailleurs
clandestins si je puis dire pour être un
peu violente dans l'air du temps non
mais que voilà donc on a cette idée
ensuite l'intercommunalité alors ça
c'est un sujet on voit bien il y a des
relents voilà bon personne ne REM en
cause l'intercommunalité je pense que
l'intercommunalité a rendu service à
beaucoup de petites communes bon
maintenant vous avez raison
l'intercommunalité c'est comme un
syndicat d'élu c'est une organisation
que l'on a créé pour faire ensemble des
choses qu'on peut pas faire seul mais
l'intercose ça n'est pas une strate qui
fait des opéas sur les choses bon alors
la loi nôtre a eu ses malheurs euh voilà
parce qu'on a une vision théorique
d'efficacité par le seuil enfin bre bon
tout ça ça doit être derrière nous nous
on ne revient pas sur l'intercommunauté
on revient pas sur les sœurs on va pas
voilà par contre on a pris des
dispositions d'engagement et proximité
dans 3ds pour améliorer la gouvernance
c'est-à-dire on a instauré
la conférence des
maires c'est quand même un monde qu'on
soit obligé par la loi de dire il faut
un St bon mais bref on l'a fait voilà on
a rendu obligatoire l'information à tous
les élus municipaux de l'ordre du jour
et du compterendu parce que vous l'avez
dit très justement et ça c'est très
important on perd des élus on a de la
perte en ligne parce que des conseillers
municipaux voient des décisions se
prendre dans des endroits où ils ne sont
pas et que ils disent ça sert à rien
qu'on participe à un conseil municipal
tout a glissé à l'interc voilà donc ça
c'est un c'est un c'est un sans doute un
sujet ensuite je pense que vous avez
évoqué aussi dans la facilitation de
l'exercice du mandat on va dire de
l'ingéerie l'importance des secrétaires
de mairie et vous savez qu'on y
travaille beaucoup grâce à vous et moi
je souhaite qu'on qu'on aboutisse et
qu'on reconnaisse que la secrétaire des
mairies la secrétaire de mairie c'est le
couteau suisse elle a des
responsabilités énormes je raconte cette
anecdote tragique où un une commune a vu
son PLU attaquer et a été condamné par
parce que la secrétaire de Maie qui
n'est là que de jours par semaine
n'était pas là le bonjour il fallait
envoyer pour respecter l'échéance au
personnes associé des choses
l'avocat de du du citoyen qui a fait un
c'est un recours pour des motifs
personnels bref à sa checklist il a
regardé ah vous êtes voilà donc on voit
bien l'enjeu et la responsabilité ça
c'est très important puis il y a un
point qui moi m'a semblé important et
qu'il faut qu'on soulligne vous l'avez
très bien dit c'està-dire on doit pas
simplement respecter et permettre le
pouvoir d'agir mais c'est le pouvoir de
décider et je partage ce que vous dites
c'estàd à un moment la complexité des
choses le risque de judiciariser
fait que les maires peuvent à un
moment être entre les mains je le dis
sans connotation négative mais de
l'administration parce que c'est très
compliqué très complexe alors que le
maire il est là pour donner l'impulsion
et décider et qu'on a besoin d'une
administration extrêmement compétente
mais qui est une aide à la décision et
qui est en charge d'une mise en œuvre
entre guillemets bien
réglementaire voilà et que je pense
effectivement que former les élus c'est
très important et que moi quand j'étais
maire je me souviens la première
formation des c'était sur les finances
locales bon moi je trouve que pour moi
c'est plus le sujet le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est comment vous formez à la conduite
de projet à l'animation d'une équipe et
vous avez très bien dit comment la crise
covid n'a pas permis de constituer le
collectif et comment du coup une équipe
qui n'est pas constituée se ite avant de
l'être à la gestion de crise à écouter
les concitoyens tout en faisant une
démocratie qui associe les gens mais qui
affirme le pouvoir de décision de voilà
donc on a des des des vrais sujet
là-dessus donc on voit bien que c'est un
ensemble de sujets et qu'en tout cas il
y a aussi un point et vous l'avez évoqué
c'est comment on simplifie comment on a
un état déconcentré renforcé qui fait
que que vous soyez mère d'une commune de
100000 habitants ou d'une commune de 10
habitants vous pouvez appeler le
sous-préfet ou le préfet et que vous
n'avez pas besoin d'être puissant pour
être entendu et comment l'État doit être
en
amont pour vous accompagner nous on a
développé les rescrits ça veut dire que
quand vous avez un projet un peu
compliqué vous pouvez appeler l'État qui
va vous
suggérer une méthode en tout cas vous
indiquer les risques ça veut dire dire
que quand vous entamez votre action vous
êtes sécurisé aujourd'hui personne n'est
capable de nous dire le nombre de rcrits
qui ont été mis en place les préfets
n'en ont pas parlé les maires ne savent
pas et les préfets où les contrôles de
l'égalité h c'est quand même un problème
et que je pense qu'on a aussi et vous
l'avez dit un devoir d'information
auprès des maèes des dispositions qui
sont mises en place moi je suis
stupéfaite quand j'entends des collègues
ma enfin pardon euh voilà on guérit
jamais de la fonction de maire moi je
suis plus maire mais bon me dire non
mais enfin François je comprends pas que
vous pas bah je dis non mais attends ça
existe ah ben oui comment je ne sais pas
donc je pense que les préfets doivent
être des verpés de la loi ils doivent
aller dire que le travail qui est fait
ici au Sénat alors parfois il participe
de la complexification bon mais c'est
pas facile de ne pas complexifier quand
vous devez prendre en compte des normes
sanitaires des normes environnementales
des normes de sécurité bref mais en tout
cas je pense que il y a eu dans des
textes depuis engagement et proximité on
appelait ça des corrections d'héritant
beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
mais comment voulez-vous qu'un
maire puisse avoir le temps de regarder
toutes les lettres d'information voilà
et j'ai entendu il y a pas très
longtemps un sous-préfet me dire oui ben
on a envoyé une note au maire bah je dis
non vous arrêtez ça vous proposez une
vision aujourd'hui voilà et vous où vous
allez voir les maires pour leur
expliquer ce que c'est vous faites un
rôle de partenaire voilà en tout cas
voilà je voulais vous remercier sachez
que nous sommes très attentifs voilà au
travail qui est fait que nous notre
mission c'est vraiment enfin vous savez
bien on est la chambre des territoires
et que c'est notre mission c'est notre
envie c'est pour ça qu'on s'est tous
engagés au Sénat de faciliter de
reconnaître et d'affirmer que ce temps
difficile pour les maires et les élus
municipaux vous l'avez dit c'est
compliqué c'est courageux quand on a
auditionné le maire de Saint-Brévin
Lespin c'était glaçant parce que le
maire de Saint-Brévin Lespin nous a
expliqué comment s'était passé cette
histoire de cada qui relevait de la
compétence de l'État et comment il s'est
retrouvé tout seul avec une maison à
laquelle on avait commencé à mettre le
feu et que personne n'est venu
l'accompagn alors même qu'on savait
qu'il y avait des des risques et ce
maire il était dans une solitude absolue
et c'est lui qui prenait c'est comme par
gros temps voyez vous prenez tous les
vagues et vousvez même pas de Canau de
sauvetage et donc je je pense que il y a
aussi un rôle très important des préfets
des sous-préfets alors la plupart sont
des gens plutôt très bien mais que
aujourd'hui l'État ne peut pas laisser
un maire seul dans des circonstances qui
un moment se trans transforme en tempête
donc merci
vraiment donc le 16 novembre nous allons
rendre le la première partie du rapport
avec les collèges avec les collègues de
bonhomme et Kouge et puis nous
poursuivrons les
derniers les deux derniers tomes de
notre mission seront rendus
mi-décembre merci beaucoup madame la
vice-président merci
vraiment CIS c'est c'est un sujet
important pour nous tous parce qu'on est
on est vraiment confronté à la nécessité
de conforter l'ensemble des des maires
et des conseillers municipaux voilà
alors chers collègue et je je le dis
devant Catherine le 7 décembre alors on
auditionnera la ministre Dominique
fort qui conduit un travail ben
Catherine vous étiez particulièrement
active l'autre jour à la Convention
voilà et nous onons aussi deux table
rond euh sur les les fameux rapports
dont dont je parlais les de autres donc
on invitera la la M bon vous avez la
courtoisie la gentillesse de venir
aujourd'hui mais nous vous inviterons
voilà parce que il est important que
nous fassions ce travail d'une manière
collective et que nous qui vous
représentons nous vous entendions c'est
important madame la Présidente nous
aussi de notre côté qu'on continue à
faire évoluer nos propositions avec ce
qui a été dit à la Convention il y a de
jours et avec les échanges qui vont
avoir lieu à l'occasion du congrès des
maires absolument nous sommes nous
serons très heureux de découvert merci
beaucoup chers collègues jeoural juste
rappeler que le 16 novembre à 8h30 nous
démarrons par le rapport par une a par
le rapport aussi sur l'intercommunalité
en nouvelle-polynésie alors c'est un
côté exotique pour nous parce que on
parle pas forcément de de de d'outrem
ici mais c'est une mission que nous
avons faite à quelques-uns à la demande
de quelques collègues Polynésiens et à
la demande du président Larcher et je
pense que la manière dont est organisé
ce territoire qui est grand comme
l'Europe je je je le rappelle très
insulaire euh voilà avec des sujet de
déchets d'eau potable et
d'intercommunalité un peu particulière
ça contribue vraiment à notre réflexion
euh voilà merci à tous en tout cas et à
cet après-midi pour ceux qui le peuvent
merci la
présidente